they came in their thousands opposition
leaders activists to protest the
nine-year jail sentences for the acting
chairman of Bangladesh nationalist party
tari Rahman and his wife zubaida Rahman
is the son of former prime minister
khalidazia the BNP say the corruption
trial was politically motivated
the protest against the false verdict
handed against Tariq Rahman and his wife
zubaida by the government we don't
accept this verdict
demonstrators are also continuing to
demand the resignation of the government
and prime minister Sheikh Hasina many
years say the last two general elections
were either rigged or fraudulent
opposition activists and leaders are
brave the red
in recent months Western Government led
by the United States and Rights group
have criticized hasina's Administration
for cracking down on anti-government
protests but government leaders remain
defined and rejects any call for
caretaker Administration before a
general election due later this year
our focus is on elections and Sheikh
hasina's government has pledged to the
general public to conduct free and fair
and violence-free elections
in recent weeks hundreds of opposition
leaders and supporters have been
harassed intimidated and arrested before
and during the rallies the United
Nations urged Bangladeshi police to
refrain from excessive use of force
during protests
this is part of our movement to restore
democracy we are willing and ready to
sacrifice everything for this they will
not be able to restrain us anymore
the political climate here appears to be
increasingly confrontational in the
run-up to the election later this year
the U.S government recently described
the political situation in Bangladesh as
unstable
the opposition Alliance says it will
continue to press home its 10 demands
for change with the resignation of the
government top of the list
[Music]